vous êtes prêt on va faire une interview
24 heures avec le centre joue un rôle
central où c'est toute une journée avec
vous jean luc lahaye c'est le matin
c'est le bordel chez vous via la tête
dans le cul pourquoi le matin on zappe
je connais pas votre téléphone sonne
depuis des heures c'est quoi la seule
arrivée il est rangé ou votre téléphone
il est débranché vous avez ratées la
peine c'était qui d'après vous feriez
pour s'excuser et verser enfin jean-luc
lahaye quelle heure est il c'est tout en
général 13h30 14h comme beaucoup comme
buffy envahisseurs conway
il ya quelqu'un à côté de vous dans
votre lit c'est qui oui le mécanicien
parce que c'est quasi la même mais
cannes pareil c'est de l'entretien vous
vous savez qui est à côté de vous
combler mais laissez moi vous savez vous
de vitriers cambouis sur les dossiers
cinquante braquage
non mais quand vous vous réveillez comme
ça vous toucher la terre vous savez qui
c'est en principe oui vous levez donc
vous habiller comme alors voilà vous
fait quoi en premier toilettes relais
dans un petit mener ses toilettes
toilettes vous arrivez dans la salle de
bain vous regardez quelle partie de
votre corps dans le miroir en premier
jean lui ce qui me précèdent
ah oui sa maman dans l'ombre une douche
elle est super froide vous hurlez vous
engueuler la terre entière qu'est ce que
vous dire non ça m'est arrivé récemment
tu nous fasses j'aimerais douche froide
et très agréable je recommande à tout le
monde ah oui oui dans le soir premières
secondes qui est oui oui c'est quand
même pas dire vous êtes mais la trappe
et le gel douche c'est quel parfum
voilà un constat savon à l'ancienne
jamais ramassé le savons
très dangereuse en cas de gel douche
vous mettez à chanter sous la douche
chanter quoi jean luc ce que j'entends
la radio donc pas tes chansons
la personne qui était dans votre livre
c'est quoi ce moment là elle dort elle
dort encore beaucoup plus longtemps
ouais c'est à présent la monnaie vous
arrivez dans la cuisine jean-luc il ya
plus de café vous tuez qui s'est pas
jacques vabre a dressé pour moi vous
retrouver un vieux juin vous en faites
quoi ya pas ça chez moi
au fait il est quelle heure là à ce
moment là 17h20 non 14h14 est en retard
n'ont procédé à aucun rendez-vous avait
avant qu'un avant 15 16 heures moi j'ai
quoi là bas ce qui reste une part de
pizza froide dans le frigo vous êtes
capable de la manger l'impossible a
maintenant je bois 5 10 voire dix cafés
on n'est ce pas une demi heure le
courrier je regarde un peu la télé de
trois infos comme ça je me mets émerger
quoi oui ouais d'accord du flore
l'impact le gardien se voit le temps
qu'il fait dehors vous devez faire quoi
cet après midi là par exemple la rentrée
parce qu'ayant préventive
oh
ça c'est important vous recevez un colis
une valise elle est bien cette humides
par fitch et vous est-ce que vous
enfermez la personne non celle inverse
vous enfermer la personne qui était avec
nous pour un usage sexuelle ultérieure
ou voulu donner la possibilité de fuir
de faire quelques allers-retours cela
dit votre téléphone sonne juste à ce
moment là c'est nikos de la star ac qui
vous propose de faire la star ac qu'est
ce que vous lui dit ravie je fais
comment ça en invité ouais alors vous
êtes en ligne quand vous avez un signal
d'appel c'est votre ex femme que faites
vous
je la prends parce que 20 autres
importants d'accord vous passez devant
un marchand de journaux vous acheter
quoi alors
une fois par semaine une fois par ouais
ouais gala matches 1
voici un bouquin sur résidence et
secondaires et machin ma cellulite
abonnés cd m dos c'est normal vous les
achetez une fois par semaine coup et 90
et j'achète parfois liberty et un titre
vous prenez un taxi 2 dans les grosses
têtes qui fait quoi
je prends rarement le taxi way en vérité
vous aimez pas le chauffeur de taxi non
non non j'irai place un fort bon coup
nous ne verrons rien bon vous allez à
votre studio là vous avez travaillé un
peu non oui chanter un peu j'enregistre
un nouvel album voilà tout à fait pour
rester quand même temps à peu près dans
le sens studio ouais ça varie entre 2
heures et une partie de la nuit alors
vous sorti du studio et à ce moment là
dans la rue vous voyez pas c'est une
fille de 12 ans en minijupe et robail
nos papas des jeunes vous appelez qui
pour passer une bonne soirée
des copains ah ouais voilà où ni comment
ni quand ils font des soirées 100
villages comme ça ça se termine vers
quelle heure un couvre-feu à 8 heures en
prison le dernier repas est à 18 heures